[Música]
Boa noite, minhas amigas, meus amigos.
Sejam muito bem-vindos para mais uma
live. Hoje temos bastante perguntas,
então não teremos tempo para fazer
configurações aí, considerações, na
verdade, sobre artigos científicos, OK?
À medida que vocês forem entrando, por
favor, se identifiquem, dê o seu boa
noite, deem a sua saudação.
Vamos começar logo, né? Eu não vou nem
esperar as primeiras pessoas se
manifestarem porque temos muitas
perguntas, né? Vamos começar aqui
mostrando então
as perguntas de hoje.
Primeira pergunta é bem longa, tá? Não
sei nem se eu vou ler.
Vou tentar ler assim rapidamente para a
gente não ficar perdendo muito tempo
aqui com a leitura.
É basicamente um homem de 28 anos,
esquecimento e ansiedade,
problemas de concentração, problemas
intelectuais.
Essa pergunta acho que foi feita semana
passada. Pode ter relação com autismo,
esquizofrenia, TDAH? Eu falei sobre isso
semana passada.
Fale sobre sintomas e tipos de demência.
Se no início pode ser confundido com
outras doenças, por favor.
E como saber se é Alzheimer? Alzheimer
com 28 anos é extremamente raro, tá?
É mais comum. Já falei isso na última
live que isso é mais provável que seja
ansiedade ou TDH, né? Qual tratamento
você ministra para curar alzim ou outros
tipos de demência? É óleo de coco,
azeite de oliva, cúrcuma, crimarina,
bemina. Pode ajudar? Podem.
A demência no início é mais fácil de
curar, sim, mas isso não é demência com
28 anos. Dia cetogênica pode curar
demência, pode ajudar muito.
Se uma pessoa for com determinados
sintomas mentais, o senhor através de
análise de perguntas minuciosas pode
identificar qual é o problema?
Já é melhor ir psiquiatra, tá? É melhor
situação psiquiatra, como o Calegaro,
né? o Juarez Calegaro,
que é um psiquiatra integrativo.
Então, eu falei que o mais provável, já
foi descrito semana passada, que isso
fosse TDAH ou ansiedade.
Crianças e adultos com autismo t
dificuldades
que afetam não somente a memória,
mas também
a questão do comportamento social, né?
Em relação à sua pergunta dos tipos de
demência, você tem o Alzheimer, você tem
a demência vascular, você tem a demência
de corpos de Liwi, você tem a demência
frontemporal.
Esses são os quatro mais comuns. Tem
também a demência da hidrocefalia de
pressão normal e tem raramente a doença
de Cotfeld Jacob, né, que é o densa
priônica.
Você diferencia um tipo de demência da
outra através de história médica
detalhada,
testes neuropsicológicos e exames
estruturais com petis scando cérebro e
também ressonância nuclear magnética de
cérebro.
Teste que você pode fazer em casa é o
teste SG, que é o self
administredognitive
exam, mas esse isso aí é um teste
paraoso, tá? Você pode também fazer o
teste Moca, né, que é o Montreal
Cognitive Assessment, ou pode fazer o
teste Slums, que é é da faculdade lá de
South Carolina.
Isso também eu fiz um post recente disso
aí lá no Instagram, como fazer testes
rápidos para demência, tá? Mas 28 anos
não é demência, tá? Esquece isso que não
é,
tá? E como eu falei, o óleo de coco, o
azeite de oliva e cúrcuma ajuda em caso
de demência, com certeza, mas não são
tratamentos isolados.
E o esquema recode para o tratamento
dessas condições tem que ser bastante
abrangente,
tá? Então, homem de 28 anos, sintomas
escritos são muito mais prováveis de ser
TDH com ansiedade.
É possível transtorno espectro autista?
Sim, mas geralmente tem outros sintomas
associados como problemas sociais, eh
problemas de
sensoriais também, tá? Então tem que
passar por uma avaliação
neuropsicológica aí abrangente para
fazer o diagnóstico. Além de passar com
o psiquiatra, eu recomendo Juarez
Calegado.
Vamos pra próxima pergunta.
A dieta mais indicada para quem para
quem tem depressão é a dieta cetogênica?
No meu ponto de vista, sim. Tá?
Na dieta cetocarnívora,
a pessoa experimenta o estado cetose com
a mesma frequência e intensidade da
cetogênica?
Depende da quantidade de carne que come.
Se comer muita carne, não vai entrar em
cetose porque aminoácido vira glicose.
A única diferença entre as dietas
cetocarnívora e cetogênica que a
cetocarnívara tem mais proteína e jejum
diário. Depende do que você tá chamando
de cetocívara. Eu não sei qual a fonte
que você consultou, mas se tem carne
demais, não vai entrar em cetose. Então
não não faria sentido esse termo ceto
carnívora se a pessoa comer carne
demais. Certa vez você diz que é difícil
alguém se manter muito tempo na dieta
cetogênica. Sim, a maioria das pessoas
têm muita dificuldade. No caso, a
cetocarnívora é mais fácil. Aí seria a
dieta hiper eh proteica e também é
difícil, tá? As pessoas enjooam depois
de um tempo.
Dieta ceto carnívora reverte sintomas de
Alzheimer. De novo, se tiver carne
demais, não. Para quem faz musculação, a
dieta ceto carnívora é mais indicado que
a cetogênica.
não é indicado para quem faz musculação.
Aí seria uma dieta
realmente mais low carb. Tem gente que
fala que faz cetogênica, mas eles eles
comem uma carca de carboidrato logo
depois do exercício. Então não chega a
ser uma acetogênica não.
Dieta aceto canívora coloca doenças
autoimunes em remissão
em alguns casos. Sim. Deixa eu só mudar
um pouquinho aqui porque não tá do jeito
que eu tinha configurado antes,
né? Tá fora da ordem que eu tinha
colocado antes. Não sei porquê.
Tá, eu vou para essa pergunta aqui
porque essa que eu tinha, eu acho que
ele mudou a ordem de novo aqui. Dr.
Alan, qual é o tratamento para controlar
tosse forte com escarro verde? E tenho
feito lavagem das narinas diariamente.
Usei NAC 600 mg, 15 dias e parou uns 5
dias os sintomas. Agora retornaram.
Desde sexta-feira tem que tomar
antibiótico. Veja os atendimentos para
casas respiratórias no Rio Grande do Sul
explodiram.
É até arriscado ir um plantão do
hospital.
Muitos casos de influenza.
Bem, não é só cor do escarro
que determina se é bactéria ou não, tá?
50% das infecções de trato respiratório
superior são por vírus e o antibiótico é
dado errado, tá?
Tem estudos recentes confirmando que
essa coloração verde não é um bom
indicativo.
Então o que que você vai ver que pode
ser um indicativo de infecção
bacteriana?
febre alta persistente,
malestar acentuado, piora dos sintomas
ao longo dos dias que não teve uma
resolução com os analgésicos comuns, tá?
Dor facial intensa ou sensação de
pressão no seios da face. Então, a febre
desses daí é o mais pidedigno, OK? Febre
alta persistente.
O ideal é fazer uma cultura da secreção
para ter certeza se tem bactéria, tá?
Quais são as opções então? Se os
sintomas não melhoraram após o NAC, né?
Então você poderia estar utilizando
lavagem nasal diária,
continuar fazendo.
Mantém ambientes bem arejados e usar
oidificador. Hidratação adequada.
Incorporar alimentos antiinflamatórios
como alho, limão, gengibre e mel.
Continuar o nac ou retomar.
Pode usar xaropes com enzimas
digestivas, né? bromelina, né, por
exemplo, ajuda, tem propriedade
expecturante, né, que é a enzima do
abacaxi, anti-inflamatórios naturais
como curcumina e bozoélia para ajudar a
reduzir a inflamação das vias aéreas e
realmente evite
ir ao ponto socorro porque pode piorar a
situação mesmo, tá?
Agora, essa febre continuar muito
persistente, você vai obrigatoriamente
tem que procurar uma assistência médica,
não precisa ser necessariamente pronto
socorro. Você pode procurar um médico no
consultório de encaixe, tá? Ou uma
vídeoconsulta, às vezes pode também ser
uma opção.
Boa parte das cúrcumas vendidas nas
lojas naturais mercados são falsas.
Acha melhor cúrcuma em pó ou suplemento?
A cúrcuma e suplemento tem que ser
acompanhada pela pimenta preta.
Como você suplementa? Quais efeitos
colaterais? Qual a dose segura da
cúrcuma? Vamos lá. Um monte de pergunta
em uma só.
Existem sim cúrcumas adulteradas no
comércio.
Existe um pigmento chamado cromato de
chumbo, que pode ser utilizado para
fazer essa adulteração
e é utilizado para melhorar a aparência
do produto. Então tem estudos mostrando
que a cúrcuma de Bangladesh
tinha concentrações de chumbo muito
superior a recomendada, 483 partes por
milhão.
E além do cromato de chumbo, tem também
o amarelo de metila ou amarelo de
metanila.
Tem pessoas que adulteram e colocam
amido, colocam corante, sudã, materiais
de enchimento, como g
para identificar a teração, você tem que
observar a cor amarela ou laranja
uniforme,
que pode não ser natural. Então, se
tiver uniforme demais, pode desconfiar
que pode ser uma adulteração.
Uma textura granulada ou em pó
diferente, um odor químico ou rançoso e
um sabor excessivamente amargo.
E sempre prefira suplemento para fins de
tratamento, tá? A cúrcuma, como o
tempero, é mais para prevenção.
O pó de cúrcuma tem apenas 3 a 8% de
curcumina, enquanto que estratos
padronizados vão conter até 95% de
cucuminoides. Então, o suplemento de 500
mg pode fornecer até 400 mg de cocumina
pura, se for desse tipo aí, 95% de
cucuminoide. E quanto que uma colher de
chá de cúrcuma em pó, fornece apenas
cerca de 15 mg, tá? Então, a cúrcuma
tempero é para prevenção, não para
tratamento.
Lembrando que o consumo de com gordura
aumenta a absorção da cúrcuma, pimenta
preta também, que vocês já sabem disso.
Você pode inclusive utilizar a
bioperina, né, ou biopiperina
que tem na manipulação para aumentar a
absorção em até 2000% da curcumina.
A dose recomendada de curcomina, né, na
forma de produtos de suplemento de alta
concentração, né, desses 95% de
cucuminoide, é de 500 a 1500 mg por dia,
tá? Essa é a dose padrão, mas tem
estudos mostrando até o uso de 10.000
1000 ou 10 g de cocumina
para colulite serativa, mas seria uma um
custo muito elevado, né? Nesse caso, 10
g de cocumina concentrada é bem alto,
mas tem estudo mostrando que pode ser
utilizado sobre supervisão médica para
colite serativa.
E você pode usar de 2 a 60 mg de
piperina a cada dose de curcumina para
aumentar absorção.
Quais são os efeitos colaterais
possíveis, né? Você pode ter náusea,
diarreia, aia, feeses amareladas,
flatulência, distensão abdominal, tá? E
tem contraindicações, distúrbios
hematológicos, hemorrágicos,
problemas de vesícula biliar, pode
acontecer de não poder usar, gravidez,
anemia e cirurgias.
E a cúrcuma pode sim ser utilizada para
prevenir câncer, né? porque ela tem
vários mecanismos de ação
anticancerígena,
é um dos fitoterráficos mais estudados
para essa finalidade.
Teve estudos em modelos animais que
demonstraram prevenção de câncer de
mama, esôfago, colon, que é intestino
grosso e fígado.
E um estudo clínico fase dois mostrou
que a cucumina associado à quimioterapia
convencional melhorou a sobrevida em
pacientes com câncer de intestino grosso
avançado.
OK.
Próxima pergunta. Aides, mesmo com os
remédios, ainda tem poucos tratamentos
para minimizar os sintomas
ou os medicamentos minimizam? Uma pessoa
com essa doença tem que tomar muitos
medicamentos diariamente. A medicina
integrativa substitui os medicamentos?
Não, suplentes são eficientes, deve ser
suplementos, né?
Bem, atualmente os antiretrovirais são
muito eficazes para
combater aí os sintomas da AIDES, né,
inclusive de suprimir a doença, tá?
Então isso é fato. Isso eles evoluíram
muito nos últimos 20 anos.
Estudos mostram que mais de 90% das
pessoas que tomam a terapia
antiretroviral,
conforme a prescrição, alcançam níveis
indetectáveis de HIV no sangue dentro de
12 meses. Então, índice bem alto.
Então, cerca de 90% tem supressão viral
e 66% fica um carga viral totalmente
detectável.
E os outros que não tm a carga viral
indetectável ficam com elas muito muito
baixas, tá?
Então, a pessoa que tá com essa carga
viral não detectável, ela não consegue
mais transmitir o vírus através de
relações sexuais.
E aí, modernamente falando, já se aceita
que ela tenha relações sexuais sem
preservativo nesses casos.
E aparentemente a expectativa de vida
dessas pessoas já está próxima de uma
pessoa normal.
Tem vários regimes hoje de comprimido
único e que permite que muitas pessoas
tomem todo o tratamento em apenas um
comprimido por dia, tá? Tem uma
combinação, por exemplo, que é
bicaravir,
entricitabina
e tenofovir comfenamida, tá? Em outras
aqui também, que é uma sopa de letrinha,
não vou falar.
Os efeitos colaterais
de medicamentos para HIV pode ser
diarreia, cansaço, erupções cutâneas,
mudança de humor, náusea, dor de cabeça.
De longo prazo pode ter problema de
densidade óssea, aumento de risco de
doenças cardíacas e colesterol alto.
E além dos usos antirretrovirais, você
pode estar associando aí vários
suplementos que não substituem esses
antiretrovis, tá?
que seria a vitamina D, o zinco, seria
ômega-3, selênio, vitamina C, tá?
Então, nada assim super especial. O LDN
é relatado que pode ter um efeito
antiretroviral, mas eu não usaria de
jeito nenhum isoladamente, tá? naxona de
baixa dosagem,
apesar das frutas estarem fracas em
nutrientes, mas comer uma mão por dia,
só pelo fato de uma mão ter muitas
fibras e beneficiar o trânsintestinal,
pode evitar o câncer, o trânsito
intestinal normal pode evitar câncer.
O consumo regular de mamão, como ele tem
fibra e substâncias, também são muito
úteis, né, anti-inflamatórias,
sim, é recomendado, tá? Existe pesquisas
que mostraram que a pectina, que é a
fibra solúvel do mamão papaiar maduro, é
capaz de inibir o surgimento de lesões
pré-neoplásica no intestino. Isso foi
estudado em ratos.
Então o estudo mostrou que foi feito na
USP, né, que as fibras do mamão maduro
poderiam induzir morte celular
programada em células cancerígenas.
E o mecanismo envolve uma proteína
chamada galactina 3, que é expressa por
alguns tipos de tumor
e ele é responsável por aumentar a
migração das células tumorais. Então a
pectina se liga a galectina 3, impede
que ela se ligue à células cancerígenas.
Esse mesmo mecanismo acontece no câncer
de próstata. Existe um suplemento que
chama-seol,
né, que inclusive é utilizado para
câncer de próstata também.
Então, transtintestinal normal é muito
importante para prevenir o câncer de
tecido grosso.
Então, as fibras combatem a constipação
e reduz o contato das mucosas no órgão
com moléculas perigosas.
Então, a redução do tempo de trânsito
intestinal diminui exposição às toxinas
do intestino. Então, é importante ter o
intestino funcionando bem. E as fibras
também são alimento para as bactérias
boas do intestino que vão ter ação
antiinflamatória através da produção de
ácidos grássicos cadeia curta.
Em relação ao abacate,
ele tem mais fibra assim que uma mão,
tá? Enquanto que o mão tem cerca de 2 g
de fibra por 100 g, o abacate tem 7 g de
fibra por 100 g.
Então o abacate médio tem 12 g de fibra.
Isso vai ser bem interessante porque
praticamente vai ser aí metade da
recomendação diária de fibra, dependendo
do tamanho da pessoa. Se for uma pessoa
pequena, né?
Você pode usar as duas frutas. Apesar
que eu sou mais fã do abacate pela
questão de ser uma fruta com alte de
magnésio, tem gorduras saudáveis,
mas você pode usar os dois, tanto
abacate quanto
o mamão,
mas de preferência ao abacate, tá? Uma
pessoa acorda e a porta aberta transmite
luz solar, mas a luz solar não toca na
pele. Eh, apenas é visível, pois o
ângulo não permite irradiação solar
direta. Se a pessoa nessa circunstância
fica deitada mais de uma hora após
acordar e fica, desculpa, pergunta tá
muito confusa aqui, tá? Vamos lá. Já sei
quem fez a pergunta, né? a pessoa que tá
com obsessão com luz solar aí, que eu já
respondi várias vezes sobre isso.
Vamos lá. O processo de reconhecimento
do despertar pelo relógio biológico, ele
vai depender da fotorrecepção, tá? que é
a maneira como a gente sincroniza o
relógio interno com os períodos de luz e
escuridão. As células na retina, elas
vão perceber a variação de iluminação do
ambiente quando o dia amanhece vão
capturar comprimentos de luz próximos ao
tom azul.
Então, mesmo que a luz solar não toque
na pele diretamente, só ela ser visível,
né, pela retina já é suficiente para
afetar o relógio. OK?
A luz natural, especialmente na primeira
parte do dia,
ajuda a sincronizar nosso relógio
interno e vai inibir a produção de
melatonina e preparar o corpo pra
vigília, ou seja, pro período do dia. E
tem uma estrutura no cérebro que é o
núcleo supraquiasmático
que recebe informações sobre a luz
ambiente através dos olhos. Então não
precisa do contato direto com a pele,
ok?
A luz do celular, que é luz azul,
especialmente à noite, é um fator
complicador.
Então, essa luz azul emitida pelas telas
de dispositivos móveis, né, confunde o
nosso relógio, imita a luz natural do
dia, então isso atrapalha o sono.
E quando você pega o celular, o
smartphone, logo ao acordar, você força
o corpo a pular os importantes estágios
de onda cerebral.
teta e alfa e direto do estado delta
para o beta, tá? Então não é recomendado
você meter a cara no celular logo se
acorda.
Então nesse cenário hipotético de você
ligar o celular logo depois que você
acorda,
o seu relógio vai receber sinais mistos,
né? vai ter o sinal positivo da luz
solar visível e o sinal problemático da
luz azul intensa do celular. Isso pode
causar desregulação.
Então, nos primeiros 15 minutos que você
acorda,
né, você evite o celular
para você poder ter contato mais efetivo
com a luz natural.
Em uma pergunta no Instagram, você
respondeu que indica ômega3 equalize
para uma mulher grávida. Deve ser
qualive, né? Mas uma resposta anterior a
que você indicou Davita. Não, são duas
marcas que eu indico desde sempre, não é
que eu indico uma em relação à outra. As
duas marcas são boas, tá? Eu não fiz
nenhuma mudança de indicação, tá?
Equali, sempre indiquei, sempre indiquei
também o Vitafor, só que a Vitafor não
era uma das primeiras marcas que eu
falava, não.
Você me explicou
eh que lentilhas
seria melhor para mim. Comi lentilhas e
passei muito mal, né? Paciência. Não
come mais. Agora não sei qual é a pior,
o feijão lentilhas. Não coma nenhuma dos
dois. Não coma mais leguminosa em geral,
tá?
Estou tomando e isolado hidrolizado da
marca True Source pergunta: "Pode ser
somente ao deitar?" Pode.
Quando eu sento, encontro a perna em
objeto duro, eu fico de cócoras. Eu
sinto dormência. Se for muito tempo,
essa dormência dificulta a minha
locomoção, pois eu perco força nas
pernas, mas passa o que pode ser.
Rins. Se for rins, quais exames e quais
marcadores dos exames?
Não, não é rins, tá? Pelo que você tá
descrevendo,
isso é parestesia provocada pela
compressão de nervo, tá?
A domência pode ser compressão de nervo
ou até redução do fluxo sanguíneo quando
você mantém uma posição por período
prolongado.
Essa posição de cócoras
tem vários á posturóis que podem
pressionar os nervos ou reduzir o fluxo
sanguíneo nos membros inferiores.
Você pode, nessa posição um pouco
forçada colocar muita pressão nos nervos
e reduzir o fluxo sanguíneo.
Não tem nada a ver com o rim, tá?
Na verdade, é o contrário, problemas
renais podem causar dormência, mas é
contexto bem diferente que você tá te
falando aí por causa da questão da
ciência renal grave, eh, causa uma
neuropatia urêmica por excesso de ureia
no sangue e isso pode levar a
adorbência, tá? Mas isso é casos graves
de espência renal,
mas facilmente investigar veio com
simples exames de sangue. É só você
fazer exame de uré creinina.
Em alguns casos o exame de cistatina C.
Tá bom? Mas quase certo que isso daí é
compressão dos nervos. Não tem nada a
ver com o ri não.
Posso tomar uma cápsula de 500 mg de
cúrcuma teor 95% com 5 mg de piperina e
mais uma cápsula mesmo teor mais essa
sem piperina.
Então ficará 1000 mg por dia. Pode
interesse é não emagrecer. Como assim?
Não é para emagrecer cúrcuma. É um
anflamatório, né?
Dará certo? Dará, mas eu não entendi
direito o que você quer dizer com o
emagrecimento. Que cúrcuma não é para
emagrecer, para ter ação
antiinflamatória anticâncer.
É possível ter o mesmo efeito da dose
mínima
indicada por você no suplemento de
cúrcuma, plantando o pé e colhendo em
casa.
Bem, precisa atingir 500 mg de
curcumina, que seria a dose terapêutica
padrão, você precisaria de
aproximadamente 9 g, 9 g de cúrcuma
pura, né? Isso é uma colher de sobremesa
cheia de cúrcuma.
Mas eu sugiro que você use os
suplementos concentrados com 95% de
curcumina.
Então você pode estar adicionando essa
colher de sobremesa cheia de cúrcuma com
os 200 mg de pimenta preta. Isso pode
aumentar a disponibilidade, né, já que
você quer usar a cúrcuma caseira e
utilizar a gordura que aumenta a
absorção também. E também dividir a dose
em várias doses menores de áreas também
ajuda.
Você pode cultivar em casa, não é
difícil. Você pode plantar o risomas em
vasos grandes, 50 cm de profundidade,
mantendo temperatura entre 20 e 35º,
usar um solo argiloso, bem drenado, com
matéria orgânica e você vai ter a
primeira colheita das flores com 120
dias de plantação.
Na proteína isolada de vergilas tem
óleossacarído. Estudei um pouquinho. Eu
acho que meu que meu problema não são só
fitatos. Que exame posso fazer para
saber?
Não sei, tá? Não, não sei se a proteína
isolada de ervilha tem óleo comossa
sacarídeos. Não,
se você tá falando isso, que
provavelmente você estudou sobre isso.
Exame para saber o quê? Se você tem
intolerância ao sacarídeo. É isso?
Desculpa, não entendi a sua pergunta.
Bem, vamos ver se te ajudar de uma outra
maneira aqui, porque para mim não tá
muito clara essa pergunta não,
mas por enquanto vamos vamos continuar
aqui. Depois a gente volta nessa
pergunta.
Como saber se meu celular libera pouca
radiação? Como saber a quantidade
liberada? Quando está com pouca bateria,
libera mais.
Desligado, libera. Qual marca? Qual
pior?
Bem, existe uma medida que chama-se S ou
de absorção específica.
Isso teoricamente você pode obter do
manual do aparelho no site do
fabricante,
no site FCC, que é o site americano de
Comissão Federal de Comunicação,
em listas especializadas, como do
escritório federal alemão de proteção
contra Radiação.
Anatel considera seguro valores abaixo
de 2 W por kg. O FCC americano considera
1.6 W por kg e a Alemanha até 0,6,
tá? Então você vê que até uma diferença
grande de um país pro outro. Os
celularis homologados pela Natel tem
valores médios,
segundo eles, abaixo dos limites
estabelecidos, a média de 0,2
W/ kg.
E é verdade, quando o sinal tá fraco da
torre,
o aparelho emite mais ondas de radiação
para compensar.
Mas não tem a ver com a bateria, não tem
a ver é com a distância da torre, tá?
Quando o sinal tá fraco e o aparelho
desligado não transmite radiação, mas aí
tem que ser, dependendo do modelo, a
bateria tem que tá desconectada, porque
eu sei que o iPhone ele não fica
totalmente desligado, não.
Marcas que tm maior radiação, tá?
Segundo vários estudos, as marcas topo
da lista são as chinesas, a Xiaomi e a
OnePlus, tá? que liberam mais de 1,7
W por kg.
O Motorola que americano, né, o ED
também libera nessa faixa aí de 1,8 W
por kg.
E as marcas com menos radiação é a
Samsung ZTE, tá?
E alguns modelos do Motorola, tá? Como o
G5 Plus e o Moto Z.
Dicas para reduzir exposição, usar fone
de ouvido com fio durante a chamada, não
deixar o aparelho próximo do corpo,
evitar chamadas e preferir mensagens de
texto. Evitar usar o aparelho quando o
sinal tá muito fraco, não é bateria, o
sinal fraco. Colocar em modo avião na
hora de deitar. E para usar a internet,
prefiro o Wi-Fi do que o
a internet do 4G. 5G, tá?
Berberina, cine marina e cúrcuma. Desses
quais eh é o mais anticâncer e
desinflamador.
Pode usar sim, todos o mesmo dia e não
precisa de intervalo, tá?
Difícil falar qual o melhor, tá? Mas eu
diria que os a berberina e a curcumina
estariam aí meio que empatadas em termos
de potência. a C Marina estaria um pouco
fraca em relação a isso, tá?
Mas eu não tenho essa informação que é
certeza que um é mais forte que o outro,
tá bom? pode tomar junto, não tem
necessidade de dar intervalo de doses
entre um e outro, mas faça de
preferência com acompanhamento médico.
Na live passada você falou que a
beberina é cara e pode não ter o mesmo
efeito na mediformina,
o mesmo efeito pra diabetes, né, que eu
quis dizer, mas mesmo assim ela ainda é
ótima prevenir câncer. Bem, vamos falar
um pouquinho das comparações entre os
dois em relação a câncer.
Estudos mostram que a beberina,
metiformina tem sim muitas
características parecidas.
Podem ser excelentes medicamentos para
tratar o diabetes tipo 2. Apesar da
metifumina ser um pouquinho melhor para
isso. Pode ser para obesidade, pode ser
para doença cardíaca, tumor, inflamação.
Dependendo da fonte, tá? A beberina,
sim, pode ter um efeito idêntico à
mediformina.
Isso é
variável da fonte que você vai
pecar.
Porém, a bberina tem um uma questão de
atividade superior à mediformina na
regulação do metabolismo lipídico, tá?
Vai ter reduções maiores nos
triglicerídos e colesterol total.
E a viverina tem sim propriedades
anticancerígenas bem documentadas.
Ela atua várias através de várias
múltiplas vias de sinalização celular
e a propriedade anticancerígena da
beberina é maior do que da metformina.
Sim. Tá.
Até que se prove o contrário. A marca C
para óleo de coco tem um óleo selo
orgânico mais caro. Devo comprar com
selo orgânico? Faz diferença?
Bem, supostamente quando tem
certificação orgânica, ela
tem assim a certificação que significa
que foi cultivado sem uso de pesticidas
e passou por uma auditoria de autoridade
competente.
E aparentemente a Copra é o primeiro
óleo de coco prensado a frio certificado
pela Ecosset do Brasil.
E segundo consta, a COPRA é auditada
anualmente por técnicos do Instituto
Biodinâmico, garantindo protocolo
Sustentáveis.
E a tua pergunta se vale a pena
investimento, eu diria que sim, tá?
Porque esse selo supostamente
eliminaria, né, a questão de
contaminantes, o resíduo de pesticidas
que pode interferir no organismo. E
parece que a certificação é rigorosa
sim.
Então,
creio que você pode confiar.
Vi que saíram novos estudos e alguns
médicos estão dizendo que aquinase
reverte uma calcificação das artérias.
Os estudos que eu vi não é de
calcificação, tá? É um pouco diferente,
na verdade reverte
a placa do endotélio, não
necessariamente a calcificação, tá? Não
é a mesma coisa.
Então, tem vários estudos clínicos e
revisões temáticas que mostram que a
natoquinase pode reduzir a espessura da
camada íntima média da artéria carótida
e o tamanho das placas ateroscleróticas.
teve um estudo de 1000 participantes e
uso diário de 10.000 unidades
FU, né, de natoquinasi por 12 meses,
resultou numa redução média de 21%, tá,
nesse índice aí da camada íntima média
e de 36% do tamanho das placas
e teve um efeito
somado aí sinégérgico com vitamina K2 e
aspirina. Então, a combinação de
natoquinase, vitamina K2 e aspirina teve
um efeito sinégico e potencializou os
benefícios cardiovasculares.
Nós sabemos que a anatoquinase tem uma
atividade potente, fibrinolítica,
antiinflamatória, antioxidante, pode
melhorar o perfil lipídico. Eu gosto
muito, eu inclusive tomo todo dia.
Agora, a causicação arterial é um
processo um pouco diferente, tá? Ele é
associado à teresclerose.
Os estudos que eu mencionei, eles
focavam na redução da progressão da
terosclerose, na espessura da camada
íntima média e no tamanho das placas e
não necessariamente na reversão da
calcificação. Então não tem estudos
clínicos robustos mostrando que a
natoquinase reverte diretamente a
calcificação, tá? Entenda que são duas
coisas diferentes.
Vai reduzir as placas ateroscleróticas e
melhorar os parâmetros de espessura.
OK?
Então, a transclerose sim vai atuar.
Reversão de calcificação a princípio
não. Tá, pelo menos não tem estudo
comprovando isso.
Sou ectomorrofo e quero ganhar massa
muscular. É necessário o protein
creatina não é fundamental o protein,
tá? Você pode comer só mais proteína que
vai dar certo também, tá?
Quais marcas de o protein isolada você
usa?
Tem várias marcas aí. Tem a growth
suplementos, tem o Dux Nutrition, tem o
Integral Médica, tem o Max Titânio, tem
o Vitafor,
tem a também a da Essenia, né, que é bem
caro, mas é muito bom também. Athletica
Nutrition, OK? Então são as marcas aí
recomendadas
e não é fundamental. Se for para
escolher entre protein e creatina,
escolha a creatina porque ela vai ter um
efeito mais importante do que o protein,
tá? Então não é obrigatório tomar o
protein. Você pode só aumentar o seu
consumo de proteína diária.
Para manter boa saúde bucal, quantas
vezes deve se escovar? Três vezes ao
dia, tá? Essa recomendação em relação a
fio dental
é uma vez ao dia, tá?
pelo menos uma vez ao dia. Você pode
usar até duas ou três vezes ao dia.
Então, escova duas vezes após as
refeições principais e uma vez antes de
dormir, tá? Pelo menos isso.
Tem um detalhe interessante também. Se
você puder esperar meia hora depois da
refeição para escolar, é melhor, tá?
Ah, quais são os períodos do perigos,
né, do do fio dental? Tem um estudo que
foi publicado no jornal de Exposure
Science Environmental Epidemiology
e disse que alguns fios dentais contêm
compostos, tá? que chama Pfas, né? Ol
polifloroalquílico
alquílicos, né?
São substâncias tóxicas que pode se
acumular no organismo.
Então, escolha marcas de fio dental que
não tenham esse químico
e que também que não contém o fluor, que
é um indicativo da presença do PFAAS.
Então, uso incorreto também do fio
dental pode dar problemas mecânicos,
causar lesões, pode machucar e cortar a
gengiva. Então, tomar cuidado com
movimentos de serra paraa frente e para
trás, que pode empurrar bactérias paraa
gengiva.
Use uma quantidade adequada de 40 cm
para fazer a limpeza adequada e faça
movimentos suaves ao redor de cada
dente.
A técnica correta de utilizar é 40 cm de
fio. Enrole nos dedos médios, deixando
10 cm entre eles. Segure entre o polegar
indicador e passa suavemente entre os
dentes em formato de C.
Ultrapasse cuidadosamente a linha de
gengiva e use um trecho novo para cada
dente.
Quanto tempo uma pessoa contaminada com
a tem para tomar os medicamentos para
evitar o vírus se instalar?
Quem se expôs ao vírus, né, no caso, por
exemplo, se furou com alguma agulha
contaminada, tem até 72 horas
para iniciar a profilaxia.
pós exposição.
Então, tão 72 horas, tá?
E se puder começar nas primeiras 2 horas
é melhor ainda.
Quanto mais precoce, maior a eficácia da
profilaxia.
E o tratamento deve ser mantido por 28
dias consecutivos ininterruptos.
Quais são as situações que a profilaxia
estaria indicada?
Eh, como eu falei, né, se furou aí com
algum objeto contaminado, relação sexual
desprotegida,
violência sexual
e contato com material biológico
contaminado.
Qual os melhores suplementos para
refluxo gástrico
que não interfere na produção de ácido?
Ômega-3 não interfere. Melatonina tem
estudos mostrando que
ajuda no refluxo gastroesofágico.
Tem estudos aí de alguns anos falando
sobre isso.
Isso é curioso, né? Porque vocês pensam
em melatonina quando
somente pensa em sono, né?
Então, a melatonina ajuda a melhorar a
função do esfíncter esofágico inferior.
A glutamina também ajuda na melhorando a
reparação da mucosa.
Os prebióticos também ajudam.
A cúrcuma sem piperina ajuda também.
Agora o zincarnosina ele diminui pouco a
acidez do estômago, tá? Então você
perguntou os que não
interfeririam na produção de ácido.
Qual suplemento limpa
o organismo da radiação do celular? Não
tem nenhum suplemento que faça isso, tá?
Eu
que eu recomendo que você faça é manter
o celular longe do corpo, usar, como eu
já falei em outra pergunta aí,
os fones de ouvido com fio,
evitar os dispositivos nas 2 horas antes
de dormir, não dormir do lado do
celular, carregar o celular fora da
cama,
deixar o aparelho em modo avião,
desligá-lo durante a noite, tá? Não tem
suplemento que faça isso. Existe aí uns
uns remédios quânticos que supostamente
fariam isso, mas eu não ponho a minha
mão no fogo não, tá? Até lembro que fiz
um curso há uns 3 anos atrás e falaram
desse suplemento aí para que era
quântico, mas eu não não põe a mão no
fogo não.
Em qual local posso comprar mudas de
cúrcuma? Açafrão verdadeiro. Acho que tá
fazendo uma confusão entre cúrcuma, que
é açafrão da Índia e açafrão da terra, e
cúrcuma verdadeira, que é o
crocussativos, tá? Eu acho, tá falando
de cúrcuma, tá? Você tá fazendo uma
confusão.
A cúrcuma longa, que é a o açafrão da
terra ou açafrão da Índia, é uma planta
que a gente fala muito sobre ela, porque
ela é muito conhecida, é muito estudada,
mas existe o açafrão verdadeiro que é o
crocusativos, que também é um
fiteráfico, tá?
Então sites você pode estar comprando
planta mundo, você pode comprar mudas de
bubos calibre 4 por entrega imediata.
Desculpa aí, eu tô falando agora do
açafrão verdadeiro, tá? O crocusativos.
Então a planta mundo, ela oferece mudas
de bubos calibre 4. Eh, e essa espécie
diferente da cúrcuma longa, né? Ela
precisa de frio para florir, então é
melhor para região sul do país ou região
de de altitude.
E tem também Mercado Livre anunciando
mudas de açafrão verdadeiro, que é o
colocos ativos. Agora, a cúrcuma, muito
mais comum, né, que é o açafrão da
terra, a cúrcuma longa é tranquilo de
plantar porque o temperatura é mais
compatível com uma parte do Brasil.
Tem um site chamado Flora Monte Claro,
que você que você pode comprar os
risomas, né, do
da Cocuma longa.
Mercado Livre também vende, o Sebrai
também tem informações sobre
fornecedores nacionais e internacionais.
Então, recapitulando, a cúrcuma longa é
fácil de cultivar no Brasil. Agora, a
cúrcuma verdadeira, o crocusativos é
mais difícil porque precisa de frio, tá?
Existe possibilidade de contrair aides
ou outras doenças pelo beijo. A
transmissão de adides pelo beijo é
extremamente rara, tá? Não se a pessoa
tiver uma lesão na boca.
O vírus não é facilmente transmitir pela
boca porque tem enzimas na boca que
destrói o vírus, tá?
Tem apenas um caso documentado de
transmissão de HV pelo beijo. Para você
ter uma ideia como é raro. Isso foi na
década de 90
e envolveu um beijo profundo com sangue
presente na boca de ambos os parceiros
e porque tinha filas aberta nas bocas
dos dois.
Então, para que um beijo transmita HIV,
tem que ter eh feridas sangrantes na
boca de duas pessoas ao mesmo tempo e um
deles ser contaminado.
Agora, doenças que são muito mais comum
transmissíveis pelo beijo, herp simples,
tá? O citomal vírus, a sífiles é é
possível, apesar de raro também, tá?
Muito raro a gonorreia, tá?
Após o afio dental sair o sangue nas
gengivas, o que pode ser? Pode ser
gingivite, pode ser periodontite,
pode ser uma técnica inadequada de
higiene usando o fio dental, como eu já
comentei, causando lesões traumáticas,
excesso de força, movimento inadequado,
tá? Pode ser algum problema que tá
aumentando o sangramento, como
deficiência de vitamina C, uso de
medicamentos anticoagulantes ou
antiagregantes plaquetários, alterações
hormonais, condições médicas como
diabetes, tá?
Então, se o sangramento tiver
persistente, tem quear um dentista.
Existe uma condição chamada genivite
gravídica,
onde condições hormonais alteradas da
gravidez podem aumentar a placa
bacteriana, inflamação gigival.
Ainda recomenda o orgânico natural, deve
estar falando da marca, né? Sim, eu
recomendo. O alho pode evitar
entupimento de artérias, sim,
especialmente o alho negro, tá?
Envelhecido ou fermentado, né? Que é o
Klic, é o melhor que tem para isso, tá?
Então o alho vai reduzir formação de
placa, vai ajudar a controlar o LDL,
evitar a oxidação do LDL, vai reduzir
algumas gorduras do sangue, vai melhorar
a elasticidade dos das artérias, tem
afeito antiinflamatório, antioxidante,
inibe a agregação plaquetária. Então o
alho, de modo geral tem essas
propriedades, mas o alho negro
fermentado que olha, que é o melhor para
isso, tá?
Bem, tem algumas perguntas que eu pulei
aqui, vão voltar,
tá? Essa que eu já respondi. Caristenia
aumenta a testosterona na mesma medida
que a musculação? Não. Aumenta a força
muscular, mas não a hipertrofia. Ah,
não. Você tá perguntando de
testosterona.
Até onde eu sei, não aumenta da da mesma
maneira, tá? Se a pessoa pratica
listenia em vez de musculação, ela
também consegue reverter e prevenir essa
compenia. Sim, ajuda a prevenir essa
compenia também e reverter, tá?
Mas não tão eficientemente quanto a
musculação. Já notei que alguns alhos
roxos possuem a cor roxa bem forte,
enquanto que outros tm alhos tem cor
roxa fraca. Isso significa que há uma
grande diferença na qualidade nutritiva.
Não tem a ver com os polifenóis, né?
Quanto mais roxo, mais polifenol. Não,
que eu sabe não tem a ver com a tóxico.
Meu pai quer comprar azeite de oliva
extravígem na nossa cidade. As opções
são poucas e não tem o que você indicou.
O galo e tem andorinha.
Falei para ele que tem que ser puro. Tem
que ler o rótulo, tem que ver se é uma
um azeite extra virgem com baixa acidez,
tá? Eh, ele falou que é muito caro as
marcas indicadas por você. Me pergunta,
conhece essas duas marcas? Sim, conheço.
São marcas bem tradicionais.
Qual o perigo de comprar azeite de má
qualidade? Você vai ingerir um óleo de
má qualidade.
Em que nível é é arriscado as marcas do
mercado serem falsificadas, mesmo
aprovadas pelas instituições?
Não entendi a pergunta. Você quer saber
qual que é o nível de risco de ser
falsificado? Não tem como responder
isso, né? O falsificado adulterado tem
efeito próximo ao original? Não, lógico
que não, né? Procura, procure boas
marcas, né? É isso que eu digo para
vocês. Não tem como garantir quantos por
centos vai ser de falsificado.
No tratamento de esbiose, existe
situações que o senhor usa antibiótico,
ao invés de antibióticos naturais? Sim,
tem situações que tem o cibo, você pode
usar rifaximina com metronidol em vez de
usar antibiótico natural, mas para longo
prazo é melhor os antibióticos naturais.
Meu médico passou si porro mais alguns
suplementos.
No meu exame deu que estou com disbiose
e dificuldade de gerir proteínas.
Seria talvez por causa que tem herne de
átom e com isso diminuição de produção
de ácido no estômago que elevou a
disbiose.
Sim, a admissão de ácido no estômago
ajuda a aumentar a disbiose, sim. Tá? E
atrapalha a digestão de de proteínas,
tá?
Qual seria a sua opinião?
Opinião sobre o quê?
Então, faz parte do tratamento da
disbiose aumentar o ácido do estômago,
tá? Eh, tomar cloridade da betaína ou
até o ácido clorídrico diluído, tá?
Então isso faz parte também debiose. Tem
que aumentar acidente do estômago se
você tiver com hipocloridria. Não sei se
é isso queria saber, né? E tem casos sim
que é aceitável se usar antibiótico, tá?
Então eu acho que eu respondi essa
pergunta.
Isso aqui eu já respondi.
Ahã. Tinha uma pergunta que eu não tinha
respondido.
Pera aí.
Eu acho que era do era negócio da
ervilha, né? Deixa eu ver se eu acho
essa pergunta aqui.
Ã,
bem, pelo que eu vi aqui, a resposta
depende do método de processamento dessa
proteína de ervilha, tá? para pegar o
isolado proteico.
Sim, as ervilhas têm naturalmente
óigossacarídos,
é o caso da estaquiose, da verbascose e
a rafine.
Tem uma tecnologia desenvolvida
especificamente para produzir isolados
de proteína de ervilha com baixo
conteúdo de óleossacarídeos.
E o processo envolve ultrafiltração com
cortes de peso molecular de 50 a 100
kodaltons,
que consegue separar o ôigossacarídeo da
proteína.
Então esse processamento resulta em
redução significativa da flatulência,
né, dos gases e melhora da
biodisponibilidade.
Então tem que buscar um produto que
tenha esse produto, esse processo
químico, né?
Então aí acho que a pergunta que você
fez em relação a exames para identificar
intolerância ao legossacaríticos, né?
Você pode fazer o teste para ver se tem
cibo, né? O teste de gases espirados,
né? né, tanto de hidrogênio e metano
como sulfeto de hidrogênio.
Porém, esses testes respiratórios de
hidrogênioes vão detectar frutose,
lactose e sorbitol que são fermentados,
né? Agora, o caso dos fructanos e
galactoossacarídeos,
que são óleossacarídeos, eles não
aparecem nos testes respiratórios, tá?
Vamos ver aqui.
Acho que o resto já respondi tudo.
Ah, não tem esse aqui.
O mamão ele tem muitos pesticidas?
Sim, é bem comum ter pesticida. Se eu
comer mamão e obviamente descartar a
casca, fica OK? Não, não fica OK não,
porque ele penetra dentro da fruta. Ou
mesmo assim corre o risco de absorverda.
Corre risco, sim. Tá.
Gente, hoje teve muita pergunta, né?
Curioso isso, né? Tem semana que tem
pouca.
Bem, deixa eu olhar aqui,
Eliseu, só me desculpar, mas eu não vou
responder pergunta ao vivo hoje, não,
tá?
Boa noite, Eliseu. Boa noite, Alice
Vogel. Boa noite, Maria Alice
Jurandir,
desculpa, Maria, Maria, não, Maria
Helena.
Tem alguma pergunta que eu respondi aqui
que ficou confuso, tá? Não sei se a
pessoa que fez a pergunta tá ao vivo,
mas eu posso est esclarecendo algum
aspecto de pergunta que eu respondi
aqui, tá? Aí eu não vou responder mais
perguntas porque já estamos com uma hora
de live, tá? E tem tinha mais de 30
perguntas hoje.
YouTube colocou dois comis de 20
segundos na live para mim hoje. Isso
nunca tinha acontecido. Estranho, né?
Estranho. Mas na live de hoje você está
falando. É, ela falou hoje, né? Você
pode fazer o exame de LDL oxidado,
Jurandi, tá? Ou e também a
polípoproteína A1 e a polipoproteína B.
Então tem AO A, AO B, LDL oxidado e pode
também fazer um exame de lipidograma
avançado que vê o número de partículas e
e o tamanho das partículas.
Isso aqui eu respondi, tá? Não tem um
exame específico para oligossacarídos,
tá? Porque o teste de gás espirados pela
boca, ele vai pegar mais é frutose e
outros tipos de
sacarde que não são oligosacarídos.
É, essa questão do comercial aí tá
estranho, né? Que vocês estão no grupo
fechado, não deveria ter no comercial
aí, né? Não tava sabendo disso.
Bem, pessoal, muito obrigado aí pela
participação de vocês. Eh, eu vou pedir
a gentileza de vocês não colocarem mais
de uma pergunta por
hã
item, né, lá do do formulário, tá? senão
fica cinco, seis perguntas juntas, fica
às vezes confuso para mim responder, tá?
Confuso para eu responder, né?
Eu peço essa gentileza para vocês.
Bem, um abraço para você, até semana que
vem.